[Música]
la economía en directo américa de france
24 flores hurtado ya estaba conmigo en
el estudio jorge es bienvenido feliz
mañana de viernes vamos a iniciar en
europa porque se conoció el dato de
inflación de la eurozona y bueno
nuevamente de raúl este dato de
inflación de la zona que comparte el
euro como moneda común superó las
expectativas de los expertos la
inflación de la eurozona aumentó cinco
décimas en junio y se situó en el 86 por
ciento en tasa anual según muestran los
datos preliminares de la oficina de
estadística comunitaria eurostat aunque
el dato de inflación subyacente que es
este dato que excluye la energía y los
alimentos- por tener precios más
volátiles éxitos el mes pasado en un 37
por ciento lo que representa una
disminución de una décima respecto al
mes de mayo el mayor aumento de los
precios en la zona del euro viene de la
energía que en un año ha subido de
precio en 41 9% dos puntos más en
comparación también con el mes anterior
por su parte el precio de los alimentos
procesados el alcohol y el tabaco
aumentó un 8,2 por ciento en junio
frente al 7 de mayo mientras que el de
los alimentos no procesados se
incrementó en más de 2 puntos desde el
de mayo el 9 por ciento que se registró
en mayo al 11,1 por ciento el mes pasado
como sabemos la inflación lleva más de
un año subiendo ahí en europa sobre todo
de forma constante alimentada
inicialmente por las preocupaciones de
la oferta tras la pandemia y ahora por
los precios de la energía que han subido
a raíz de la guerra de rusia contra
ucrania este aumento de los precios
refuerza los argumentos para que el
banco central europeo aplique una rápida
subida de los tipos de interés a partir
de este mes como ya lo han anunciado
jugadores seguimos en el 'viejo
continente' porque la unión europea
acuerda normas para regular por primera
vez las cripto divisas así es el mercado
de los activos digitales sobre todo cada
vez más usados como medio de pago o
inversión pero que no están sujetos a
ninguna de las reglas ni garantías de
las que se rigen los servicios
financieros tradicionales la regulación
del mercado de cripto activos aborta
desde su autorización y supervisión
hasta los requisitos de transparencia
con el consumidor y su impacto en el
medio ambiente que sea uno de los temas
también más críticos sobre el uso de la
script o divisa esta regulación prevé
que para operar en la unión europea los
proveedores de servicio de cripto
divisas tengan pero deben de tener
presencia física en el continente y
recibir autorización previa de las
autoridades nacionales
el reglamento ordena requisitos sobre la
información que deben proporcionar a los
inversores sobre el uso que harán sobre
sus fondos sus obligaciones o los
riesgos de la inversión las reglas se
dirigen a quienes emiten y comercializan
cripto activos y cubren la transparencia
y la divulgación la autorización y la
supervisión de las transacciones estas
nuevas reglas también incluyen medidas
contra la manipulación del mercado la
prevención del blanqueo de capitales y
la financiación del terrorismo entre
otras actividades delictivas el acuerdo
ahora debe ser ratificado formalmente
por los estados miembros y la eurocámara
para entrar en vigor 'jorge cambiamos de
información gras y nos venimos a nuestro
continente americano en argentina se
asegura que se está cumpliendo las metas
de lo acordado con el fondo monetario
internacional pero ya hablamos de este
acuerdo de refinanciación del préstamo
de más de 40 mil millones de dólares el
viernes pasado el fm y dio su aval a la
primera revisión del programa de
facilidades extendida suscripto con el
gobierno argentino habilitando un
desembolso de unos 4 mil 10 millón de
dólares- la portavoz presidencial
gabriela cerrutti reaccionó a los
cuestionamientos sobre si el gobierno
cumplía o no estas metas escuchamos los
números que nosotros tenemos
recomposición del salario estaba
avanzando no al ritmo que siempre uno
quiere que nunca los números de la
macroeconomía o los números que se miden
tienen que ver con las expectativas que
uno tiene en su propia vida o en su vida
cotidiana pero son números que nos
muestran que estamos en el camino
correcto en que la situación está
mejorando día tras día jorge en ecuador
sido punto final las protestas tras un
acuerdo firmado entre el gobierno y el
movimiento indígena a quien las lideraba
ese acuerdo le llamaron acta de la paz e
incluyó ciertas exoneraciones reformas
políticas y reducción en el precio de
los combustibles los 18 días de
movilizaciones que se convirtieron en el
mayor reto político del presidente
guillermo lasso concluyeron con la firma
de esta acta por la paz que incluyó la
reducción adicional de los precios de
los combustibles allí a partir de ahora
la gasolina extra costará 240 dólares
por galón y el diesel 175 dólares por
galón los indígenas exigían además de la
reducción de los combustibles la
limitación de la expansión extractivista
y mayores plazos para cubrir deudas con
los bancos entre los acuerdos raúl que
se lograron destaca el aumento de cinco
dólares para el bono de desarrollo
humano una reforma a la política minera
cambio en la política hidrocarburífera
también de ese país y exoneraciones para
el sector agrícola las partes firmaron
un entendimiento gracias a la mediación
de la conferencia episcopal ecuatoriana
que dio por finalizada estas
manifestaciones que dejaron pues la
cifra más tristes en personas fallecidas
y más de 500 heridos sobre muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información económica nos vemos en la
segunda hora con más economía y nos
vamos directo a lisboa
[Música]